gathering on a bridge on the outskirts
of bangkok
gazing at the sky but it's not the
sunset
people have come to see these amateur
astronomers want to catch a glimpse of
the great conjunction
a celestial event that happens
approximately only every 20
years we will see very bright stars
jupiter is originally very bright but
when saturn is near
they will be even brighter together this
year however is extra special
the two planets are coming even closer
together than usual
the last time this happened was in 1623
but trying to see it is hard bangkok
like most cities
suffers from significant light pollution
the light of the glimmering stars
is blocked out by the glare of the
bustling city
that's why the stargazers as they're
known on social media
have set up an exhibition of the stars
at night as seen from thailand
spectacular views unseen by most city
dwellers
and pong satan thinks that after the
trials of 2020
there may be a message written in the
skies
we have suffered sadness distress worry
and tension from coronavirus
since the beginning of the year but at
the end of this year
we look up and see a bright sky and it
will give us hope
that can keep us moving forward
astronomers believe that the star of
bethlehem or christmas star
is actually the great conjunction that
occurred in the year 7 bc
and when it was last this bright galileo
the man considered to be the father of
astronomy
was still alive although he makes no
record of having seen it
but for the astronomers of today it
presents a unique opportunity
this time the great conjunction happened
two or three months after saturn and
jupiter came
close to the earth so that makes them
look brighter
you'll be able to see the great
conjunction until the night of the 23rd
and if you miss it it'll come around
again in 2040
but if you want to see it this bright
you're going to have to wait
another 400 years and with everyone on
this planet trying to stay socially
distant because of coronavirus
other planets are managing to get closer
together
tony chang al jazeera cha chong sao
thailand